vom 16
oktober 2016 trainierte das iphone
multinational batterien am
trainingsgelände mañana westlich von
banja luka in bosnien herzegowina
die übung mit den namen kult response 20
16 ist teil einer langjährigen trainings
serie in diesem raum über 750
soldatinnen und soldaten aus österreich
großbritannien der türkei portugal und
ungarn trainierten den gemeinsamen
einsatz bei dem auch einheiten der
bosnische streitkräfte integriert wurden
bereits im vorfeld errichteten
österreichische pionier ein feldlager
inklusive geschäftsstelle für 160
soldaten bei der übung selbst stand die
zusammenarbeit auf internationaler ebene
sowie der austausch von erfahrungen im
mittelpunkt um den schutz und die
sicherheit im falle einer krise in
bosnien herzegowina aufrechterhalten zu
können
die szenarien umfassen unter anderem das
durchführen von konvois sowie das
richtige reagieren auf straßensperren
oder bei beschuss
aber auch verhandlungsführung und das
fachgerechte bergen sowie der asche
abtransports und verletzten standen am
übungsprogramm
seit dezember 2004 stehen die
österreichischen soldaten unter dem
kommando vor altea der europäischen
union gemeinsam mit ihren kameraden
unterstützen sie die umsetzung des
dayton abkommens auf diese weise leistet
österreich einen wesentlichen beitrag um
den balkanstaat auf seinem weg in eine
friedliche und demokratische zukunft
erzeugt